elle ne doit pas y couper ça veut dire
on va faire une petite interview with où
tu connais les missions que je balance
non tu balances pas comme la visite est
gentille tout le monde tout fait moi
j'aime tout le monde et aime tout le
monde c'est vrai on pouvait c'est vrai
comment crois pas non mais on va voir
s'il est vrai que j'aime pas oui c'est
tir aux pigeons
alors on commence simplement drucker
drucker j'ai vu dans un zénith denisot
michel drucker disait est ce que je
savais pas qui était sur antenne 2
drucker lui disais oui est ce que c'est
vrai patrick que tu as demandé a pu être
le samedi parce que ça t'embête d'être
en face de moi et toi tu disais oui
absolument j'ai demandé ouais ça
m'embêtait 2 mai le programme de
variétés à la limite je préfère la
concurrence il ya aujourd'hui l'autre
soir au resto au concert des restos du
coeur à l'opéra ouais je sais pas si tf1
ne diffusera lundi prochain dans tous
les cas tu as dit en parlant de michel
drucker
c'est le genre de mec tu lui mets un
copieur avec où ils demandent si tu t'es
pas fait mal aux pieds
ouais ils t'envoient bouquet de
chaussures
pourquoi parce que parce que c'est vrai
que ce mec est gentil ouais mais c'est
alors au commissariat les gens qui vont
encore mal tourner sans ne tourne pas
mal j'ai mal je dis donc voilà j'ai fait
j'ai fait rire oui c'est ce que je
voulais je parle de sabatier en parlant
de collaborateurs me fais tout ça aucune
incidence cd sabatier a dit lui c'est la
milice
c'est donc c'est un genou oui l'ami l
apos 3 elle a fait le plus pour vichy
voilà et puis toutes et tous ses
assistants il appelle collaborateurs là
il s'est émancipé l'avis de recherche et
le jeu de la vérité
voilà cinq ans que je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait une alliance entre nous ça
vole mais ça rien à voir c'est passer
par un collaborateur je vais d'étudier
un truc c'est interpréter ces compromis
non non non
est ce que tu crois que tu n est pas mal
diffusée lundi ça je crois mais c'est
pas grave ce sont même s'il ne diffuse
pas c'est pas grave oui je te dis faut
arrêter de croire
moi j'ai une solidarité quand avec ces
mecs là parce qu'on est monté au créneau
à 20h30 et ce n'était pas facile
on s'est fait taper sur la gueule de
partout et quoi qu'il en soit j'ai une
certaine solidarité
non on a avec machin on va arrêter tu as
raison on va arrêter de parler de la
télé on va parler politique coluche est
ce que finalement bon tu te fait la
tronche de coluche mais quand tu t'es
c'est la tronche de coluche à ce moment
là tu dis des choses mais qui sont ces
choses est ce qu un moment tu juste
qu'il aurait pu dire oui mais est-ce que
kg et est ce que j'aurai mesure peut pas
un peu sa personnalité by dans tout ce
que je fais juste sur la shoah est
d'accord coluche lui fait dire des
choses si tu me suis fait dire des
choses qui sont dans son ton way dans
son ton il ya des choses que je peux
dire dans son ton et lui ne faut pas que
c'est un peu too much
peut-être que c'est pas je m'en rends
pas compte je me suis jamais vraiment
posé tu veux te dis je me suis jamais
vraiment posé la question parce que
quand il était vivant et que je le
faisais il n'a jamais fait la réflexion
la cli 10h hae colicci le fait mieux il
m'avait prêté une salopette pour le
faire d'ailleurs
alors là oui on avait décidé qu'il était
président serait vice président il
s'occuperait du président et moi
le pen tu dis moi je serai débattre avec
lui le point qu'est celui d'hier
j'aimerais les battre tu crois que tu
serais meilleur qu'alain duhamel albert
du roy
ouais je pense à l'heure de vérité je
pense que je parlais avec mon coeur
parce que ces mecs là les journalistes
qui équiperait mme le pen d'abord il la
grèce ouais ça fait des années qu'on
agresse l'open donc il parce qu'on le
considère comme une sous merde et qu'on
rend sympathique peut-être s'apercevoir
que ça marche pas à la sortie
et puis il faudrait peut-être aussi se
dire que le problème de l'immigration
faut arrêter de regarder les choses dans
un sens ou dans l'autre
moi le jour où on expliquera qu'il est
aussi intolérable qu'un mec comme si tu
veux que comex se fasse jeté d'un métier
tu vois il vient pour une petite annonce
et en lui dit dehors pourquoi parce que
vous êtes noir ça c'est intolérable
mais c'est aussi intolérable qu'un mec
noir qui va demander du boulot qu'on
refuse pour incompétence et qui dit
c'est parce que je suis noir
moi je trouve qu'elle est raciste mais
aussi dangereux que l'open j'espère
qu'un jour sos racisme disparaîtra sa
proie qui en a toujours mais je trouve
que pendant un moment on a été trop
systématique c'est trop le pen c'est une
ordure etc
je crois qu'on peut discuter de toute
façon faire monter la pression des deux
côtés ça peut conduire qu'à taper sur la
gueule cause excès il ya sûrement un
moyen terme
toi tu discuterai avec lui ah ouais je
discuterai avec lui
tapie tapis tapis mais dans l'ombre et
mitterrand dont j'aime pas non je n'aime
pas je suis même si mme que du scorpion
ouais ça c'est à cause de sa maman jeune
alex les scorpions sont très voulez vous
je supporte on se pique avec la queue
derrière la tête
non je n'aime pas parce que je viens
d'un milieu pauvre d'un milieu ouvrier
ma mère travaille à usine il ya tout un
tas de gens que je connais qui sont
encore dans cette situation et l'a trahi
ces gens là c'est comme aujourd'hui le
grand argument de mitterrand c'est vous
n'êtes pas si malheureux que ça
regardez ailleurs du chômage y en a mais
y en a plus au guatemala
l'insécurité y en a il y en a plus en
yougoslavie alors il nous bourre le mou
mais par rapport à pinocchio
mais je pense surtout que je n'aime pas
beaucoup surtout parce que je pense
qu'il fait passer aujourd'hui son destin
à lui avant le destin du pays et du
pauvre con qui va bosser tous les matins
tu comprends alors sirach c'est vrai
qu'il soit présidente c'est ouais ouais
tu veux pas lui apprendre à communiquer
et toi c'est toi qui te débrouilles
tellement bien j'aimerais aller argent
j'aimerais bien lui apprendre mais ça va
tu sais chirac il a un problème il est
terrorisé devant une caméra
ouais mais est ce que c'est parce qu'un
mec est terrorisée devant une caméra en
fin de vie des difficultés à s'exprimer
que il faut y mettre un trait dessus en
disant on va prendre ce qui s'exprime le
problème de la démocratie médiatique
c'est ça un nom c'est le jeu si l'epa
président je vais pas aller tuer le
foisonnement pas son frein avec imagine
qu'un jour il t'appelle pour te demander
ce que tu penserais de l'idée c'est pas
pour parler de la télé poubelle ce que
tu penserais l'idée d'avoir des femmes
et boueuse dans les rues de paris étudie
à quoi
dis ce que je pense globalement de toi
c'est bien tu as déjà fait des conneries
j'entre en faire d'autres
deux secondes ça existe pas encore
sérieusement pour le moment non mais ça
paye ben non